you were watching television TV
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
over the past year we've probably
noticed huawei appearing in headlines
along with Samsung and Apple as it turns
out they're much bigger than just
smartphones they're a huge force in the
world of telecommunications way before
they even released a smartphone today
we'll see how the Chinese giant grew to
be one of the largest telecom
manufacturers in the world and why
they're at the center of so much
controversy Huawei Technologies was set
up in 1987 by ren zheng fee usually the
founders of companies are young and
vibrant but ren was different he was in
the midst of a midlife crisis and in his
mid 40s when he founded the company he
had plenty of technical expertise from
his time as a deputy director of the
People's Liberation Army Engineering
Corp so from the very beginning the
company has been tired in some way to
the Chinese government this will come
into play later in the story at this
point in time in the late 1980s China
was a long way behind the Western world
when it came to telecommunication
despite having a population of over 1
billion there were just two hundred
thousand phone lines when the 90s began
Huawei set up in Shenzhen a small
fishing village that has since become
the Silicon Valley of China only 30
years later firstly the company imported
switches from Hong Kong a country which
sat just across the river from China the
components were switchboards that allow
the company to manage multiple internal
and external phone lines the demand was
huge as China pushed to modernize and
those also a desire for a locally made
Chinese product rather than relying on
imports so hawawa set up a huge research
and development department that focused
heavily on analyzing the equipment that
was coming in and attempting to
reverse-engineer it within a few years
they had made the most of China's huge
cheap talent pool of engineering
graduates and created their own
switchboard they sold these throughout
China with government support and soon
began to focus on a digital version of
the switch in 1993 the strong focus of
research and development continued as
they set up new facilities in Beijing
and Shanghai and by 1996 they had their
first international client albeit only
in Hong Kong
the most important development for
hawawa was the appearance of a global
system for mobile coupled with the
incredible adoption of the mobile phone
since their founding Huawei had always
been playing catch-up with the rest of
the world fighting just to match what
was already being made but the mobile
phone leveled the playing field this was
a new technology for everyone
now Hawaii's research facilities became
an enormous asset as they leveraged them
to sign partnership deals with many of
the biggest tech firms from Intel to Sun
Microsystems to Motorola and Microsoft
by 1997 they had their own GSM equipment
in the market what many other company is
focused on handsets
who always main products or for running
the mobile networks themselves they beat
major players like Siemens
and Ericsson to win a contract to
upgrade Berlin's communication network
in the same year they created the
world's first and largest Wireless LAN
network by now there were a global
presence they had a 1,000 person
research facility in India sales office
in Berlin and major contracts in the
Middle East and we're starting to look
towards Europe in 2004 while we shipped
their first phone the c300
this would be the first step in an
extensive rise to dominance
the name hawawa translated directly from
Chinese means Chinese achievement and
with a net worth of over eight billion
dollars it seems that the company has
done just that
today Huawei are the second largest
phone manufacturer ahead of Apple and
behind Samsung but they are looking to
challenge Samsung from the number one
spot in 2019 the high-end smartphones
have been largely praised with their may
20 pro model winning and blind
smartphone camera test by Markus
Brownlee with a subject sample size of
over seven million people Huawei is
currently the largest telecom equipment
manufacturer in the world with most
countries using their equipment in their
telecommunication infrastructure more in
this later the company has a very
interesting management style in order to
stay creative and always flowing with
fresh ideas Huawei periodically rotates
the CEOs every six months they have a
1.5 million square meter campus with
Castle style buildings to move around
the campus employees can take a train
ride Huawei has their own Technology
Park and the University at their
headquarters in Shenzhen complete with
student housing qualified IT graduates
from the university are then offered
careers in hawawa afterwards the company
employs 180,000 staff the average
employee age is 29 years old the company
has invested over 60 billion dollars in
R&D alone in the last 10 years
on the point of the University and
Technology Park will seem a similar
thing with Samsung it seems like the
Asian philosophy to business is very
different
especially when the companies involved
have close ties to government it reminds
me of how the United States was pouring
money into science research and
universities during the 1960's after the
Sputnik launch such efforts resulted in
the internet back then but today this
may partly explain why Samsung and
hawawa are exploiting in success I wish
more countries who put a dedicated focus
towards the synergy between education
and business but despite all of these
impressive feats Huawei has a massive
trust problem in his infancy the company
was more or less an offshoot of the
People's Liberation Army the company
claimed that it had later restructured
to be collectively owned by its
employees but some question to what
degree the Chinese government is still
involved this has been a major stumbling
block for a number of big international
deals this is for two main reasons
firstly Huawei are accused of getting
government subsidies that allow them to
undercut the other big players they
already have access to cheap labor but
if they're subsidized it's unlikely any
private business can compete with them
on cost the second more major reason is
if the Chinese government is involved
then potentially they have access to the
data flowing through the equipment of
all the networks Huawei supplies
equipment for networks used all over the
world the NSA CIA and FBI have accused
Huawei of being a front to spy on US and
Canadian communications Huawei has
denied these claims that many experts
aren't so convinced the UK Japan Germany
and Italy have all been persuaded not to
use Huawei infrastructure in December of
2018 produced telecom began dismantling
Huawei infrastructure
this comes after New Zealand and
Australia stopped using Huawei equipment
for these security reasons Huawei
smartphones aren't widely sold in the
United States in December of 2018 the
CFO and daughter of the founder of the
company megwin Zhu was arrested in
Canada as you see in my upcoming video
China
Big Brother Edition the Chinese
government loves to get their hands on
as much consumer data from any Chinese
company at home or abroad so this panic
may not be unfounded so with all of
these accusations of mistrust where does
the company stand today well with an
annual revenue of over 92 billion
dollars and being one of if not the
biggest patent file of any company in
the world and having 197 14 500
companies use their equipment while
selling 200 million phones in 2018 it's
fair to say that they're doing well
Huawei will keep focusing on research as
it always has but in Western nations if
they want to see more growth in
smartphones or otherwise they must gain
trust a task much easier said than done
so that is the story and size of Huawei
it's interesting to look at how they
started but also the security concerns
that aren't as well known if you've
enjoyed this video let me know this has
been to gogo you've been watching cold
fusion if you just stumbled across this
channel feel free to subscribe I'll sure
you'll find a lot of interesting stuff
around here I'll see you again soon for
the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]